leute lehnt euch zurück es ist wieder so
ein video beim letzten mal haben wir 100
stunden lang eine lasagne gekocht heute
gehen wir eines meiner lieblings
gerichte am burger und geben dem ganzen
zehn stunden selbst gemachte bands
selbst gemacht das fleisch alles drum
und dran ist wird wirklich unglaublich
geil und beim letzten mal das hat mich
wirklich sehr stolz gemacht kam erst mal
das video super gut bei euch an und
derjenige der mich dazu inspiriert hat
elvis show hat selbst kommentiert und es
gefeiert deshalb heute part 2 viel spaß
damit los geht's
okay leute vergesst für das heutige
video einfach mal alles was ihr über
bürger zu wissen glaubt oder was bürger
für euch sind vielleicht ist es für euch
ein snack dem man sich nach der arbeit
holt wenn man es nicht mehr schafft
selbst so was zu kochen oder
der schnelle mahlzeit auf einer langen
autofahrt hier gehen das heute ganz ganz
anders sollen wir wollen uns einfach
zeit nehmen wir wollen die mahlzeit das
rezept zelebrieren und genau das habe
ich mal wieder gebraucht so zwischen
videos wo ich schnell drei gerichte
kochen wo stress entsteht einfach mal
wieder kochen um zu kochen
was ich hier gerade mache nennt sich
quelle stück das ist quasi eine paste
aus milch wasser mehl lächeln später im
detail leben für die brötchen die wir
auch selbst backen und ich habe die
brötchen auch ganz bewusst vorher
gedanken hätte sie auch parallel machen
können dann wäre das ganze schneller
gegangen aber
das wollte ich gar nicht ich heute die
brötchen so gut ich kann so gut wie
möglich schon fertig backen und mich
dann mit voller konzentration in den
nächsten schritten widme ich
glaube jetzt ist auch ein ganz guter
zeitpunkt um eine youtube ein schauder
zu geben dessen videos ich sehr gerne
gucke der ist ein rezept der ich sehr
gerne benutzt und zwar just went von dem
es auch das rezept für diese bürger band
und ich weiß einfach wenn man den kanal
findet auf dem man zurückgreifen kann wo
man weiß die rezepte sind punkte die
kann nicht nachmachen und wenn ich für
ein paar von euch da draußen so kanal
bin dann freue ich mich auf jeden fall
sehr darüber
auf jeden fall ist mir letztens noch mal
bewusst wurden wie viel ich auch vor der
kamera gelernt habe im letzten jahr ich
mein ich war quasi ein unbeschriebenes
blatt was das ganze angeht diese ganzen
koch thematik und ich durfte so viel
erleben und ich habe so viel
kennengelernt und so viel gelernt auch
vor der kamera
darüber bin ich wirklich mega dankbar
wenn ich so darüber nachdenke und an der
stelle jetzt auch gerade wo das jahr zu
ende geht deshalb mal ein großes
dankeschön ich habe meine gedanken dazu
letzten schon mal als instagram geteilt
aber ich bin wirklich sehr dankbar und
nehmen das ganze nicht für
selbstverständlich
zurück zum teil
das sind die ersten bürger brötchen die
ich jemals mache ihr wisst ja selbst
dass ich diese brioche burger bands die
man im supermarkt bekommt auch absolut
liebe und für mich war das auch ein
gutes experimenten zu sehen ist diese
arbeit die ganze sache wert und es gibt
nur einen weg herauszufinden und deshalb
habe ich sie einfach gemacht
nachdem wir unseren gesamten teig zu
einer masse verarbeitet haben zu einer
kugel geformt haben kam der für ein bis
zwei stunden in ein gefettetes behältnis
und dann habe ich abgewartet bis der
teig sich ungefähr in der größe
verdoppelt hat
zum glück ist der tag auch wirklich
aufgegangen ich bin ein bisschen schiss
wenn ich mit trockenhefe arbeite dass
das ganze nicht funktioniert ich habe
ein zwei mal die erfahrung gemacht aber
heute sollten einfach sein dann habe ich
ein backblech vorbereitet gefettet
backpapier drauf haben in unseren tag
ausgepackt die luft raus geschlagen und
den teig erst einmal aufgeteilt in
kleine kügelchen die ich dann ganz rund
geformt habe in dem ich sie über den
tisch gekreist habe habe sie platziert
auf dem backblech und ein umgedrehtes
backbleche oben drauf gegeben wieder für
ein bis zwei stunden
[Musik]
dann bin ich mir auch nicht mehr viel
übrig als den backofen vorheizen und
alle brötchen mit einer milch eier
mischung zu bestreichen ich habe keinen
pinsel aber ich habe jetzt mittlerweile
eingestellt ich weiß auch nicht wie ich
von allen sachen die ich habe einfach
keine pinsel in der küche haben kann
aber ab in den ofen
[Musik]
okay leute ich war wirklich so normal
stolz in diesem moment die bürger
brötchen sind wunderschön geworden und
man sieht da habe ich hier ganz gut wie
flüssig sie auch innen sind sein werden
das ganze hab ich dann unmittelbar mit
butter bestrichen die zieht richtig
schön ein und ich bin wirklich sehr
zufrieden mit dem ergebnis und freue
mich jetzt auf alles weitere das hat uns
übrigens zum jetzigen zeitpunkt circa
vier stunden gekostet und ich habe es
kein bisschen bereut als ich die bürger
brötchen gesehen habe
das fleisch für unsere pettys wollten
wir natürlich selbst ich bin zum netz
gegangen und hab quer rippe und zogen
stück bestellt eine sache davon hatten
sie nicht und habe nie irgendwas anderes
gegeben dafür dann noch ein bisschen
fett um den fettgehalt der bürger pettys
ein bisschen hoch zu schrauben alles
klein geschnitten habe ich das in einer
form platziert ausgebreitet und für eine
stunde ins gefrierfach gegeben
[Musik]
das ganze habe ich übrigens gemacht weil
beim wolfen natürlich wärme entsteht so
kann man dem ganzen entgegenwirken und
erhält die optimale temperatur und die
zarte fleisch
ich finde durch diese art und weise zu
kochen entwickelt man viel besseres
verständnis dafür was eigentlich hinter
bekannten gerichten und rezept und
steckt und welche arbeit auch dahinter
steckt aktuell entwickle ich gemeinsam
mit eric eine idee wo wir das ganze noch
ein bisschen besser zeigen können ich
will nicht zu viel verraten aber ich
freue mich sehr sehr sehr darauf und das
wird glaube ich eine ganz große rolle im
nächsten jahr auf einem kanal spielen
aber für jetzt fahren wir erstmal ein
paar schöne gleichmäßige mädchen aus
unserem hackfleisch geben das ganze im
kühlschrank und machen weiter mit dem
nächsten schritt
[Musik]
und der letzte
karamellisierte
zwiebeln
wirklich ein absolutes geschmacks
geheimnis und das einzige was man dafür
braucht es viel zeit und geduld aber die
haben wir ja heute von daher habe ich
alle fein geschnitten butter in einer
pfanne zerlassen wirklich gute menge
butter habe die mutter dann braun werden
lassen und im anschluss unsere zwiebeln
darauf gegeben und den müssen wir darauf
achten wie vor gleich die pfanne sein
wird und die lehrer sie am ende ist weil
das ganze braucht seine zeit und es
arbeitet aber auch wirklich in dieser
gesamten zeit
braten wänden zu gucken wie langsam
farbe entsteht die es immer weniger wird
in der pfanne und
es lohnt sich wirklich
[Musik]
nach ungefähr zwei stunden
geben wir ein bisschen wasser an unsere
zwiebeln und zum schluss ein bisschen
braunen zucker und das ganze noch ein
bisschen zu karamellisieren dem ganzen
wenn süßes zu geben und das ist was
übrig ist
unglaublich
[Musik]
langsam wurde ich aufgeregt ist es alles
zusammengekommen wir haben
karamellisierten zwiebeln wir haben
bürger brötchen wir haben vorgefertigte
pettys natürlich müssen wir uns noch
eine soße machen dafür nämlich ketchup
mayonnaise sind etwas gegen wasser und
cayennepfeffer und vermische das ganze
[Musik]
natürlich müssen wir unseren
selbstgemachten bürger brötchen gerecht
werden und sie richtig schön an thorsten
dafür zulässig butter in der pfanne und
lasst ihr wirklich goldbraun und
knusprig werden von unten
es ist lustig dass die ganzen
stundenlangen vorbereitungen auf diesen
moment kommen wo ich das fleisch dann
auf der leiterplatte brücke schön
angriffe von beiden seiten pfeffer salz
darauf geben und das sind eigentlich nur
wenige minuten aber nichtsdestotrotz ist
es einer der wichtigsten schritte
natürlich für unsere bürger
[Musik]
genauso wichtig ist es natürlich dass
wir schöne geschmolzenen käse oben drauf
haben dafür verwende ich diese glocken
ohne meine pace dann wenn sie durch
gegrillt sind runter dass ich noch gut
zu ziehen
da wird es auch schon zeit unseren
berger zu bauen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt es zur hochzeit alle
zutaten kommen zusammen
wir haben soße das erste partie darauf
kommt das zweite partie
das ganze wird getoppt mit den
karamellisierten zwiebeln von denen wir
auch wirklich eine ganze menge nehmen
[Musik]
die krone das obere bahn kommt natürlich
zum schluss drauf
und gebt euch jetzt diese seitenansicht
[Musik]
ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich noch
sagen soll
zehn stunden nur für diesen moment die
ganze arbeit all das kann sich jetzt
bezahlt machen und ich glaube es wird
sich bezahlt machen das jetzt probieren
diese saftigkeit ist ein monster bürger
dann hat man sich aber auch verdient
nach der ganzen arbeit das brand ist so
weich saftig rosa in
das ist unglaublich ich muss das jetzt
genießen ich habe mich auch hinsetzen
wir sehen uns gleich so sieht es hinter
den kulissen aus nach oben gedreht haben
gerade drei von diesen bürgern vom
körper nicht nein sagen würde ich an
meinem vierten essen das ist so wie
diese brioche bands die man kaufen kann
nur noch ein stück besser das lohnt sich
nicht an allen tagen aber sondern wie
heute so wie ich es gemacht haben sich
einfach mal wirklich zeit nehmen wir zum
kochen einfach nicht auf die urkunden
die keinen stress machen nichts anderes
macht dann und sich das wirklich die
sind luftig sie sind mutig dazu diese
unfassbar geschmacksintensive zwiebel
das saftige fleisch selbst gewollt ist
sowieso eine andere liga es war wirklich
ein genuss leute danke dass ihr bei
dieser reise mitgemacht hat was war das
für ein ja aber ich will gar nicht zu
setzen
bis zum nächsten video wir sehen uns
wieder macht's gut und besser
entscheiden
[Musik]